this is super interesting when
the covid relief bill passed uh with joe
biden president the 1.9 trillion where
we had 1400
checks go out to people you of course
i'm sure remember
that not a single republican elected
official
voted for it i'm not saying almost
no republicans voted for it zero uh
republican senators voted for it
zero republican members of the house
voted for it people got coveted cash
republicans democrats
independents apolitical people people
got covered cash
only because of democrats voting for it
not a single republican voted for
voted for it and we said at the time is
this going to really lead to
consequences for republicans
because there are many republicans who
will get their 1400 bucks
and never find out that no republicans
voted for it
there are many of these republicans who
will get their 1400 bucks
and say well i want the 1400 i like the
1400
i know my republican officials didn't
vote for it but i don't care
because i still got it anyway and i'm
not going to hold them accountable so we
had a
sense that you were not going to see
punishment
for republicans for voting against very
popular
covet stimulus checks that went out we
now have a new poll which finds
that 50 percent of rural voters
don't realize that it is only thanks to
democrats
that they received those 1400 checks um
americans have so far received three
direct payments from the federal
government during the pandemic
two were under donald trump one was
under democrats
the first two under trump's
administration
had huge democratic support and it was
thanks to
republicans and democrats that people
got those first two bills
but the third one under joe biden's
watch was
only because of democrats rural
objective
pac this is a super pac that is working
to build
democratic support in rural or rural as
some say areas
found that fifty percent of voters in
rural areas
uh associated the recent coveted
stimulus checks
with the democratic party 32 percent
believe they got those checks thanks to
republicans
and 11 percent believed that it was not
a partisan thing one way or the other
seven percent weren't sure
so this is a a problem for democrats for
several reasons
number one democrats are failing to
connect with rural voters
since they have half of them have no
idea
that it is because of democrats and
democrats alone that they got those
fourteen hundred dollars
and then the second part the second
problem is
uh it seems as though republicans are
mostly going to get away
scot-free with no or almost
zero consequences for opposing the
coveted stimulus
which was very very popular
if you're looking for some good news
those same rural voters were asked that
enhanced and extended unemployment who
do you have to thank for that
most of them knew that that did have to
do with democrats now what's weird is
it's all in the same bill
it it's you know i don't know this is
the type of stuff that
people like rachel bittikoffer and
others study and maybe maybe could
explain it to us
um but this does not bode particularly
well for democrats in a number of
different ways and these are really not
matters of opinion i mean there there is
a group in this country
that just has no idea what's going on
around them there's no other way to say
it these are not matters of opinion
there are you know we've talked before
there are people
who like the affordable care act but
hate obamacare and there are people who
are skeptical of obamacare
but would be okay expanding the
affordable care act and of course it's
the same thing they don't know it's the
same thing
um this is not the the
the we we are not talking about an
opinion about things
we are talking about facts and a large
swath of the population
that is clueless to the facts now some
of them are uninformed
the as the poll said 11
uh uh think that the covet stimulus had
nothing to do with republicans or
democrats
seven percent just weren't sure so some
people are are really
um uninformed some people are
misinformed they believe something that
is absolutely not true
because it's been fed to them in some
way shape or form they've been fed the
same lies for decades
they fall for all of them it's not
surprising and they can't tell
whether something is fact or fiction and
often they can't tell whether a
statement
is a statement of fact or a statement of
opinion
fox news is misinforming them
republicans are misinforming them trump
misinformed them
you know sinclair owned tv stations or
misinforming them
and they don't know any better
there's not really any clear way to get
them out of the right-wing bubble
they've watched right-wing tv they
listen to right-wing radio they go
on facebook and see things shared by
people who have the exact same beliefs
they go to their church and often get a
lot of the same stuff they have no idea
what is going on and so the question
we're continuing to grapple with
to which i don't have an answer i wish i
wish i did but i don't have an
answer how do you deprogram 75 million
trumpists
how do you do it and we've talked before
about
the retail strategy which is you on a
one-on-one basis
develop a relationship with people over
time and slowly change their views
it can take weeks or months the retail
strategy
unfortunately is not likely to be the
master programming that we need
what would be a wholesale strategy that
would work i don't know i don't even
know how to break these people out of
their
echo chamber filter bubble so we
continue to search for answers to that
is where we'll leave it today